if you tax people at work and you pay
people who don't work
don't be surprised if a lot of people
decide not to work
what causes inflation and how bad can
things be
if hyperinflation takes place in the
states the rich people who have the
money taken from them will produce a
little less
the poor people who have the money given
to them also will produce a little bit
less
and you'll have a reduction in total
income or output
10-year bond yields are not high gold
prices have not risen
and the dollar has not been depreciating
in the foreign exchanges dramatically so
what concerns you the most right now
don't make the benefits so attractive
that you cause
able-bodied people to stop working and
now these people are not going back in
the labor force because it's more
attractive
being unemployed than it is actually
going back to their old jobs
by stealing from the rich robin
literally made the poor
worse off and that is the true story of
redistribution
[Music]
you know most people don't want to talk
taxes but i'm one of those weird guys
that loves
talking and learning about taxes and my
guest it is an
expert in that area i've had them on
before three years ago in 2018 we're
having them back here and again and
that's dr arthur laffer
former member of president reagan's and
trump's economic policy
advisor in 2016 he got the presidential
i think you got the awarded with the
presidential medal of freedom
for his work that he did with the
economy with that being said arthur
thank you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
my pleasure patrick thanks for having me
again yeah so from the last time you and
i spoke you know the laugh for curve
you're
i i'm driving down here for my place
right now
my camera guy paul's like i said you
know arthur lafley says
you know the only place i know arthur
laffer from is from a movie
i said which movie he takes the video
you know which movie he's talking about
not rip but ferris bueller's day off
that's the one he takes out with ben
stein he says d
and i'm like you got to be kidding me
but to the to the person who doesn't
know uh uh your background and how you
became who you became arthur do you mind
taking a minute and just kind of giving
us your background
well you educated yale university
undergraduate then stanford
mba first and then i switched over to
econ department got to be uh
got my phd in economics taught at the
university of chicago
uh taught at usc uh i've been in
government i was a
george schultz's right-hand person in
in the white house um at first chief
economist of the omb
uh when it was formed and uh obviously
from then on over the last 52 years i've
been involved
uh with the oval office and the white
house and congress and
other governments in chile and argentina
and in
uh and in britain uh all over the world
uh in economics so
political economics and then i wrote for
a long time a lot for the wall street
journal
and i've written books and academic
stuff and blah blah blah it's all boring
stuff to everyone else except you and me
patrick
i think it's just important for people
to know your background to give you the
credibility when you say six kids
13 grandchildren four
great-grandchildren
four great-grandchildren 81 years old
and you're still going and that's your
office i think i was at your office uh
three years ago when we came down is
that the
same office same office very same one
you were in
in fact if we turn the camera this way
you can see lady thatcher's picture
between sir michael hinckey and miami
and of course uh jerry brown on the wall
here and
the president trump and reagan and you
know all the the usual characters
so so let's get into it so what i did is
uh
about a couple months we had a guest on
a friend of mine byron udell where we
started talking about taxes
and then they said you know back in the
days taxes were above 90
for nearly three decades i said what do
you mean three decades so yeah top line
was three decades
you know reagan was known for only doing
two movies he'd make his 200 grand and
he wouldn't do a third movie because why
would he do it because
he was only making six thousand dollars
on the third movie et cetera et cetera
so i went down then i started looking at
a bunch of stuff with taxes i did a
video on taxes
and i got 50 60 pages of taxes i watched
every and any video i can get my hands
on
taxes to learn about this and there's a
part of it that was very interesting and
i want to hear your thoughts on this
is when you know originally the founder
of the irs was abraham lincoln
it was during his administration that
irs got started so
he starts and he says look guys we have
the civil war thing we got to go raise
some money
i think they put the taxes up three
percent for people making
500 to 10 000 it was some tears that he
had and it was
up to six percent for people that were
making more than that
but he said if we pay off the debt that
we've accrued
from civil war we're gonna stop paying
collecting taxes income ordinary income
taxes
well ten years later they stopped having
ordinary income taxes and kind of went
away
and then comes the next round which is
hey let's do it again and
hey you know we're gonna just raise
taxes because we have to pay for world
war one
world war ii but ordinary income taxes
never went away so arthur why is
ordinary income tax still around today
uh you've got me but it really was a we
had the uh
the 16th amendment i believe it was was
uh under taft was passed by all the
states and then by congress
and so it allowed for a progressive
income tax i believe
uh the u.s supreme court really knocked
it down
at least once maybe twice and uh this
one just made it so it had a
constitutional amendment that made it
constitutional
in 1913 it was done by wilson president
wilson the
highest rate was seven percent i think
there were i think there were
uh 400 000 total taxpayers at that time
very very small group of people it
stayed at seven percent the highest rate
for the next two years
so three years at seven percent then it
went to 15 then it went to 77
in 2019-18 and then it started back down
in 1919 uh
73 where i think it stayed for three
years at 73 percent 1919 1920 1921
and then it tumbled down to the 25 range
and then
popped right back up with hoover he took
it up from
25 to 63 then roosevelt took it up to 79
by 1945 the highest marginal income tax
rate was 94
where it stayed for a long long time and
then in 1981
when the skies cleared the sun shone
forth in the earth the
animals multiplied the trees poured
fruit the fields turned green
ronald reagan brought that ray way down
to 28 and since then it's between 81 and
today
it's been uh about 20 about a little
less than 40 percent the whole time
uh the first couple years it dropped
quickly but
about four little less than 40 percent
in the years from 1943 when we had a
comprehensive income
tax until 1981 uh
i think the average rate was about 81
percent at the top so
you've had two distinct periods uh a
very high tax rate period that was for a
long time
i mean 30 38 years and then you have a
very low one for a long time which is
about 40 years something like that from
1981 to the present
and those are the two big periods but we
have a lot of bobbles and wiggles in the
middle
but i but i'm pretty familiar with all
those moves and i've got a book coming
out shortly
which is taxes have consequences which
i'm co-authoring with gene sinkfield
uh and uh and brian dimitrovic both of
them phds so
uh we've got a really good book coming
out on that and explains what the
history is of high taxes
i'm looking forward and it's it's
fascinating the fact that you can just
spit out those numbers as if like you
you know you got a computer on your head
which
many people would say you do but going
back to it going back to it
was ordinary income tax ever created to
stick around or was it just there to
raise money pay off the debt and we
don't have it anymore until
another war happens or was it supposed
to be permanent from day one
well if for a lot of people was supposed
in fact they had tried to get it earlier
after lincoln got rid of it but lincoln
got rid of it under a threat by the way
just so you know
that the supreme court did uh question
the validity of the
income tax uh and uh he did
pull that tax out quite rightly
rightfully so
but then they wanted to have an income
tax in there in the early
1900 period and that was knocked down
it wasn't until we got the 19th a 16th
amendment
that really allowed the income tax and a
lot of people at that time wanted it to
be permanent
the initial income tax in 1913 did not
contemplate world war one it didn't uh
it wasn't until 1917 1918 that they
really pushed it way up now uh in 1916
uh they pushed it up to 15
with an inkling of a war coming on but
uh bottom line is it was there basically
to uh to make sure that the rich the
very very rich the top
really very small percentage paid a lot
of the income taxes
and it was still a small source of
revenue for the whole government
so you'll see you'll see a lot of people
uh on uh more on the aoc camp will say
things like
what's the big deal if we take the top
line for the highest income bracket to
we've done it before we did it for 30
years or you know if we've done it
before why can't we do it again
it's not like anybody else is going to
be affected by but the only rich who are
already making so much money why should
they keep all their money it's the
infrastructure that helped them make
this money
what is your argument to them well i
don't mean to make an argument to them
the question is their facts
i think are really incorrect i mean when
we raise taxes in 1919
1918 to 77 and then lower those tax
rates down now this is just on the rich
that i've talked about
from 77 percent to 25 revenues
really increased dramatically the
economy improved it was the go goes
the go-go with the roaring 20s as you
know what we have found is that
when you raise the highest rate number
one
revenues go down number two the rich
are damaged uh number three to the
extent that they're not damaged they
shelter their income
all right and for the lower income
groups are hurt
and total tax revenues drop and the
taxes on the lowest
group the bottom fifty percent actually
rise
with high tax rates on the rich
let me go do you want to go through that
again i i no i want you i want you to
unpack that because i want the audience
let me unpack the first part with you
because it's really important from 1943
until 1981
all right what is that that's 38 years
something like that
the highest tax rate averaged a little
about 81 percent
something like that a very high tax
period and without kennedy it'd be much
higher
uh average about 81 percent during that
period
uh revenue growth from the top one
percent of income earners
was a little bit higher than one and a
half percent per annum
all right during that period and the
economy grew slowly
from 1981 to the present the average tax
rate
has been a little bit of has been a
little bit less than 40
throughout the whole period uh and also
revenues grew at over four and a half
percent
during that period versus one and a half
percent the previous one
and taxes from the rich the top one
percent
as a share of gdp soared while taxes
from the bottom 50 percent
not about 95 declined dramatically
during that period
so i in any way you want to cut it
raising taxes on the rich do
hurt the rich they cause tax sheltering
they cause the poor to be worse off the
economy
to be much poorer as well and they don't
collect the money but other than that
it's really a great idea patrick so
let's just bring
so as as of course as as simple as that
sounds the way you put it how come
how come there is 70 million americans
that disagree with you how come
how can maybe it's not disagree with you
why is it so hard to get the other 70
million to see the data and say that
makes sense rather than saying let's
just raise a tax on everybody
i don't know i mean maybe it's much
easier to be an accountant than it is to
be an economist
you would think if you raise taxes on
the rich if they don't change their
behavior they'll pay more and they'll
they're so rich they can afford it well
i have a story to tell if you if you
if you have a minute go for it i will
tell you my make-believe story of robin
hood
uh that i introduce economics but it
takes about three minutes or four
minutes
you know robin would wake up in the
morning and you know this is your mom
telling you the story
robin has stole from the rich and he
gave to the poor he made the poor better
off he was a hero made the rich worse
off but they could afford it you
remember the story
well the story starts off with robin
hood and nottingham he and his get
banned to marry men they don their light
green leisure suits you know the curly
toed shoes the
hats with a feather in them and they
they go running out to the trans forest
throughway
and when a richie would come by i mean a
really rich this guy didn't have a
silver spoon in his mouth
this guy had a golden goblet in his
throat all right right there
they would jump out of the bushes on him
they'd steal everything the guy had
they'd let him run naked out of the
forest back to his castle
but don't worry uh that guy has so much
left of the castle he can afford it and
do that if a guy came through the forest
was doing really well but not a
super richie they'd take a large chunk
of what he had but not all of it
if a normal everyday average merchant
came through the forest they'd just take
a token from that guy
in this in the vernacular of the modern
day society patrick
they had a progressive stealing
structure from the merchants when they
came through the forest
you with me at the end of the day robin
hood and his
band of merry men would go running back
into naughty and they'd wander the
streets of nottingham if they found some
guy who was down out some guy with
nothing i mean just nothing
they'd give him a whole pile of goodies
if they found an ordinary
sort of working poor guy they give him a
smaller bundle of goodies you know the
more you make the less they give you the
less you make the more they give you
if you found a normal everyday average
citizen walking along the streets and
nottingham
what they do is say hi my name is robin
hood i want to tell you i'm the local
redistribution station around here
i just want you to know we love you
here's five bucks take the wife out to
dinner
have a good time it's on me and by the
way if they bumped into someone rich and
nodding him they just might steal from
him too
okay now that's the story
now let me just imagine bring economics
back into your life all right
this is going to now become instead of a
moral story an economic story
imagine you were a merchant back in the
ancient days of nottingham
how long would it take you to learn not
to go through the forest
one trip maybe one trip that's all those
merchants
those merchants who were really rich
with the golden goblets in the throat
armed guards to take them to the forest
now we call those armed guards today
lawyers accountants deferred income
special lobbyists favor grabbers
all of that stuff but they were really
held expensive back then as they are now
the merchants who couldn't have formed
the armed guards they'd go around the
forest not the route around the forest
to trade
was full of rocks bumps logs holes etc
it cost them a lot more to trade with
the neighboring villages
it increased the cost of trade
dramatically both the armed guards and
the
circuits roots around there so they had
to sell their products at higher prices
at the end of the day
robin who had no contraband whatsoever
because all the guys were so heavily
armed he couldn't rip him off
he went back into nottingham with
nothing in his hands to give the poor
the disenfranchised at all and they had
to face much higher prices by stealing
from the rich
robin literally made the poor worse off
and that is the true story of
redistribution
uh and that is what exactly happens in
this society today
now i try to tell that story because i
think it's pretty understandable isn't
it patrick
very simple uh uh the challenge isn't
about how simple it is the challenge is
uh what what method needs to be taken
for the other side to say
okay this kind of makes sense in this
part raising tax is not going to be the
solution
let me let me i've got the data i've got
the data i mean
they can they can duplicate the data has
the byte administration at all reached
out to you or no
no okay what do you think about the tax
plan that they are proposing currently
right now
well i'm not really sure of what it is
and what it's going to be completely but
i think they want to raise the income
tax rate to 40
i think they want to raise the capital
gains tax rate to 43 percent
i think they want to raise the corporate
rate from 21 to 28
these are the things and they've got a
gas tax and they've got other
deductions exemptions and exclusions
they want to eliminate and all of that
stuff
uh you know if they did that i think it
would be basically reversing the trump
tax cuts
of 2017 and as such those tax cuts
extended the boom for quite some time
they led to much lower unemployment rate
of the poor the minorities of
disenfranchised
record lows a record low in u.s poverty
measures
so and also the tax revenues rose
as a result of the trump tax bills i
mean the two years after trump's
tax bill had a faster growth in revenue
than did the two years before or the
four years to two years before
so there was an acceleration in revenue
growth on the federal government now
not in corporate taxes okay duh i have
to say that to everyone
no corporate taxes went down but all the
other taxes went up as a result of the
corporate taxes going down
and if they reverse it i think they'd
get the the reverse results and i think
it would be damaging to the country
who would take the biggest hit would it
be more the employer the employee the
the middle america who would take the
biggest hit i don't really know who
would but my guess is it's always the
poor the minorities disenfranchised
the people on the lowest echelon of the
latter uh almost
always are the ones fired first i mean
benjamin hooks put it very clearly
patrick and i
i quote him he was head of the naacp if
you'll remember and
he said blacks are hired last and fired
first the only way we're ever going to
get jobs and keep those jobs is if
there's so damn many jobs
required that we get employed and never
get laid off
and i think if you have a slowdown in
this economy you're going to have it hit
the minorities and the poor
uh inner city dwellers those people
living in the hollows of kentucky
much more than other people arthur you
you've been studying economy for how
long now
i mean you gave your age to everybody
how long would you say you've studied
you know
i would assume you're reading all the
books that are out there how long have
you been studying economy
oh probably 50 years 50 years five years
so
from your experience what causes
inflation because right now you're
hearing a lot of talks you market crash
was last year hey it's coming it's
coming you're hearing michael bury talk
about the biggest market crashes coming
he came back on twitter and finally said
it again i think last week
but you're hearing more talks right now
about inflation
um what causes inflation and how bad can
things be
if hyperinflation takes place in the
states yeah let me start off about the
cause of inflation i wrote a piece in
the wall street journal
1974 which was the bitter fruits of
devaluation
the us dollar had devalued had gone off
gold
and by that we devalued against other
countries currencies i forecasted
double-digit inflation i was criticized
roundly at the time
and the double-digit inflation did come
because we devalued the currency
versus the numeraire which is gold uh
and the other countries
we don't have anything like that today
my view is that that model i used back
then no longer is applicable
because we aren't pegged to gold we
aren't pegged to other currencies at all
what you will see of course is if
inflation does hit
it will show up in the u.s dollar which
is not falling it will show up in the
10-year bond yield
which is not rising and it will show up
in gold prices
which are not rising so all today
i mean patrick very seriously uh i don't
see
any reason why specifically
we should expect higher inflation in the
near term
10-year bond yields are not high gold
prices have not risen
and and the dollar has not been
depreciating in the foreign exchanges
dramatically
so i am not currently terribly panicked
about
inflation but if inflation were to come
back
it would have no constraints there's no
reserve requirement constraints
that would hold that inflation back so
my thought right now is i don't see
inflation on the horizon
uh but if it were to come there are no
constraints
operating out there that would stop it
what i hope that's okay
uh no no i'm curious you know you're the
brains here with this this is your world
i want to learn from you i'm wrong a lot
of times
that's totally fine yeah i want to hear
your perspective never deliberately
so so what causes gold to go up what
causes gold to go up gold is the first
refuge to the cautious okay
uh you know when things are going bad
people move to gold because it's high
valuable easily assailable
uh over the centuries it has been the
one go-to thing
in times of crisis uh in the 1970s
everyone went into gold and of course
you had the price of gold go from 35
an ounce to 900 an ounce uh you know in
the 1930s
everyone went into gold but gold was
fixed in value
so the price level dropped dramatically
the reason the price level dropped
dramatically is because the real value
of gold had to increase
so uh when you look at gold it is the
first reference of the cautious and
so far there's not been a run a rush
into gold
it just hasn't happened so that doesn't
mean it won't
yeah and and there was a minute it did
but then it was back down to a normal uh
uh range that it was at what what's
what's your biggest concern like if if
if i'm speaking with you off camera
we're talking i'm saying arthur you know
there's a lot of stuff you're hearing on
the news right now market crash you know
inflation
you know uh regulation you know all this
taxes what concerns you the most right
now
financially there are a bunch of things
that i mean obviously these tax things
bother me a great deal patrick
i mean i i think we're in a bad
situation in taxes
i think this deficit spending is crazy i
mean you know when you have uh
when you have uh uh huge transfer
payments
like can i go through transfers with you
a little bit slowly and
you know when you transfer when your
transfer income you take from someone
who has a little bit more
and you give to someone who has a little
bit less you're with me on there yeah
that that's what really is
redistribution or transfer payment there
now whenever you take from someone who
has a little bit more
you reduce that person's incentives to
produce
and that person will produce a little
bit less okay
likewise when you give to someone who
has a little bit less
that person finds an alternative source
of income other than working
for receiving income so that person too
will produce a little bit less he can
make money by not working
all right the the theorem here is really
simple
whenever you redistribute income
whatever you do you
always reduce total income always it's
not a debate
the rich people who have the money taken
from them will produce a little less
the poor people who have the money given
to them also will produce a little bit
less
and you'll have a reduction in total
income or output
to see it really clearly if you tax
people who work
and you pay people who don't work don't
be surprised if a lot of people
decide not to work all right now the
lemma from this theory
and theorem is delicious uh and and the
lemma is very simply is
the more you redistribute the greater
will be the decline
in total income and that should be
self-evident
from the theorem itself so but the limit
function of this theorem i i just
delight in
uh because it's so clear this is just
math it's nothing else it's not
left-wing it's not right-wing it's not
liberal it's not conservative or
republican
it's just plain math the the limit
theorem is
if you were able to redistribute all
income so that everyone came out exactly
the same patrick if
everyone came out exactly the same there
will be no income whatsoever
and let me hit that intuitively to you
uh
to get everyone to come out the same
what you have to do is tax everyone who
earns above the average income
100 of the excess and what you also have
to do is everyone below the average
income
you have to subsidize them up to the
average income
now if you actually did that if you
actually taxed everyone above the
average income 100
and actually subsidize everyone below
the average income up to the average
income
i'll stipulate today counselor um
there there everyone will come out
exactly the same at zero
income that's what bothers me a lot
we've increased government spending
through these
through these quote-unquote stimulus
packages incredibly lahar
and it's working very much to the
detriment of this economy in this
country
my view arthur how how do you view uh
you know you've been around when there
was no crypto and then it barely came
and people kind of like well what's this
all about and then now a lot of people
who were not
uh you know believers and they were
doubters now are becoming believers
they're saying you know what i don't
think this thing's going away what's
your position with cryptocurrency and
bitcoin
i think you're probably right i i do i
did a podcast with kathy wood now you
may know who kathy wood is
she was my student at the university of
southern california and i'm involved
with her and arc as well we did a
podcast i think four or five years ago
on
on bitcoin i think it was bitcoin we did
it on but cryptocurrencies in general
and my general view is that while they
may not be a substitute for the
transactions medium called money
uh they sure are uh they sure are a
medium for
the wealth concept of money uh you know
i think that
cryptocurrencies for sure and bitcoin
for sure
is a replacement for bed let's say gold
which i talked about with you earlier
i think they this is a synthetic gold
that uh
frankly will uh satisfy some of the
needs that the gold market
does got it okay uh i think it's here to
stay i mean
i don't it's not going away now are you
in it are you somebody that's a believer
to the point where you're putting your
money where your mouth is and you're
messing as well or not yourself well let
me just say to the extent i have an
equity interest in arc
which is the kathy wood company which i
do uh
than i am but separately no i'm not a
personal investor
i'm just an old man patrick i mean i'm
81 years old
my cryptocurrencies i don't even i don't
even have a
a computer i don't do emails i have a
flip phone i mean
you know how can i do cryptocurrencies
come on
but i love them i love them you love
them but but
uh so so so how how do you like you know
there's a there's a guy named anthony
pompliano pump on twitter he's a big
uh bitcoin guy massive voice he's he's
everywhere everybody's interviewing we
had him on a couple months ago great guy
good conversation with him
he called out warren buffett and he says
you know these guys are not outdated you
know he's
warren buffett is going out there and
you know they have to kind of comment on
bitcoin what's going to happen all this
other stuff
what are your thoughts like when you
were coming up
who was the person when you were 35
years old coming up with ideas and these
80 year olds were saying arthur has no
clue what the hell he's talking about
he's lost his mind we're around we have
experience we know what we're saying
how did you at 35 view the 80 year old
that criticized your ideas
well you know at 35 i was a huge fan of
bob mundell's
who very recently passed away we did the
global stuff now
our world was a very different world in
the world today
but bob mendel and i both believe that
money was global in scope
not country and scope we both believe
very much in the sound
price rule the gold standard not some
sort of uh
monetary base standard as as exists in
the 70s and 80s
uh we also so believe very much in the
power of cutting tax rates now
when we argued our stuff and well 1930
when i was 35 that was 1975
i had done my big kemp roth tax cut
already across the board
which brought the highest rate down to
everyone said i was crazy not only
politically but economically
it was crazy weird bob mandela course
was right there at the time and
we were we we were pilloried by everyone
but
lo and behold it happened and you can
see what happened he had the greatest
boom ever with ronald reagan
and the price level tumbled uh inflation
stopped immediately after jimmy carter
and the dollar soared in the foreign
exchange market and
you know as i said the animals
multiplied the children danced in the
streets
do you think certain principles
economically
are evergreen that are always going to
be around or do you think almost every
philosophy is changing because we're
living in times we've never seen before
i mean things are
technology is moving rapidly
decentralized systems you know you're
talking about
you know crypto nft it's almost like
there's so much to take in
where some of the way of thinking in
1970 may not apply today or no
it's evergreen many of those apply still
today
well obviously the specifics are are
brand new i mean you know we had our
technologies back in the
1970s we had our technologies back in
the 1920s
these are new technologies i mean all
sorts of things are happening
uh and i told you tax rates are very
different now than they were in the 30s
and 40s and 50s and 60s and 70s
so that these are all different things
but the principles i think are pretty
much the same now
you know very simply people respond to
incentives
and if you make something attractive
through regulatory policy or through
spending programs or whatever they'll do
more of it if you make something
unattractive through taxes or through
regulatory policy they'll do less of it
so the government can
through the manipulation of incentives
change the results that occur in the
economy
and unfortunately they don't understand
it they're not very well educated
they're not very well motivated and as a
result they make things a lot worse
they've made the poverty situation in
america a lot worse
the minimum wage at 15 an hour would
hurt the poor the minorities
disenfranchised the most it would just
destroy their futures and their lives
but you know they they really are into
politics more than they are
humanitarian efforts why would it
destroy their lives
well because you get some of these
people who who just don't have the
requisite skills at present
they're young they're not well educated
they haven't had the experience of
internships and all that and they can't
get that first job at 15
an hour after being unemployed for a
year or two
sooner or later they become unemployable
patrick and then after being
unemployable for
years they become frustrated and angry
and then you have to spend a fortune
protecting yourself from them
you know you've created this under
culture of underemployed
poverty-stricken people
who who are not sharing in the
prosperity that you and i have them
and you know they have just the rights
to it as we do i mean they're human
beings too
it's only that the government has kept
them down i mean we have welfare
payments
patrick that are withdrawn once they hit
a certain level
so you know if you took a now this is
four years ago data a
single mother with two children in
philadelphia making 29 000
a year income if you take out all the
taxes in that 29 000
so you have a net income there then you
add in the economic value of all of the
social welfare spending she's eligible
for
you get the total amount she is which is
a little over 53 000
now if that woman goes from 29 000 to 79
income re because the taxes go up so
much and because all the welfare
benefits dropped so much
she's literally the same way off of at
79 000 as she was at 29 000
and you know it's a hundred percent tax
rate on earnings that's called a welfare
poverty trap so you combine those two
things the minimum wage and that
and you've created a massive enterprise
zone descript destruction package
on the poor the minorities that
disenfranchise and it just disgusts me
to the core
and what we need to do is have tax-free
zones in our country
for 15 years anyone locating the
enterprise owner's principal residence
is there
who got a job in the enterprise no
income tax no payroll tax
nothing minimum wage abolished in that
area
until they get back up on their feet and
get going and then they have the
requisite skills
to become productive members of our
society but
you know patrick when do you look at the
income tax codes
70 000 pages and all this stuff you need
to have a lawyer
you need to have accountant you need to
have a deferred income special you need
to have a favor grabber
you need to have lobbyists you need to
have all those to make it some guy in
the inner city or wherever
you know just as a simple basketball
player
comes out there great basketball band
makes a lot of money but doesn't know
how to do the
gimmicks and tricks of the uh of the of
the tax codes
and he's just hammered down and that's
why you find all these guys once they
retire they go right into poverty
and you know that's just wrong wrong
wrong for us in society to do that
so you're not you're not for minimum
wage raising minimum wage
and are you do you believe automation's
coming coming here and it's already here
but even at the highest level like
automation is coming well
automatization automatic automation
comes in
because of the minimum wage if you go to
mcdonald's and some of these other
places
they have these little screens now that
you pop there they have hamburger
flipping things you can flip 60
hamburgers at a time
and they're done perfectly they've got
all these other have you seen these new
robots
that go around delivering packages all
over the place without a person
that's all because of the minimum wage
being so damn high
that it's worthwhile for them to
technologically
replace these low-wage workers and make
sure they never do anything
if there weren't a minimum wage these
kids would get fined jobs at 10
an hour they'd be there they'd be doing
this and they'd soon work their way up
to higher wages
but no that's not what our society is
doing for them so
you are saying automation is inevitable
because these companies have to figure
out a way to save money so
we just invested we just invested into
software it took us
two years to build all in five million
dollars it helped us
it helped us not need 10 jobs that we
currently have right now because the
software's doing it automatically right
so
but do you think automation is happening
whether they raise the minimum wage or
not wouldn't the company do
automatically automate no matter what
well to some extent but no the
automation if you raise the minimum wage
that incentivizes you to automate in
that area
uh you know in other areas if you have
high paid workers
uh you automate there because you're
saving the money of those high paid
workers well there's a shortage of those
people
but there's not a shortage of low wage
workers and so what you want to make
sure you do is that the automation
is tilted towards places where there is
a
where there's a shortage of high paid
workers and not
to the people who desperately need jobs
patrick and
that's what they've done is the minimum
wage puts a government bounty
on on low-wage workers to make sure that
companies that would hire them now use
automation
so so so then are you also
if we're saying automation is no matter
what coming we're there automation no
matter what is coming
let's just say minimum wages you know it
is what it is
pick a number leave it there uh are you
also
you know the one word that created a lot
of momentum this last time around was
ubi you kept hearing our ubi ubi ubi ubi
with
andrew yang and he says well milton
friedman tried to do it he talked about
ubi even though he was milton friedman's
idea was negative you know was a
completely different system you kind of
briefly talked about it today
he says well mlk wanted to do this
what's wrong with us doing ubi right
if automation is inevitable and we're
going in that direction do you think
ubi is also inevitable you know
the basic income concept where you give
a payment
will hurt jobs output and employment
that is not my way of solving the world
of what i would not
do and let me just say it really
explicitly patrick
milton refriedman's minimum wage the ubi
all of these say
if you earn higher incomes you get taxed
on that
from the base level on that is a
disincentive all the way there
i would what i would do very simply is
i'd
do a low rate broad-based flat tax just
like i did for jerry brown when he ran
for president
in 1992 you replace all federal income
taxes all federal taxes of all sorts
with two low-rate uh low-rate
broad-based taxes you want the lowest
rate to provide people with the least
incentives
to evade or void or otherwise not report
taxable income
and you want the broader space so they
have the least place they can stick
their income
and thus avoid paying taxes if you
replaced all federal taxes
with two low-rate broad-based tax one on
value added or what
republicans call business net sales and
one on personal unadjusted gross income
so it's on the first dollar to the last
dollar you could match
all federal revenues today all of them
with two flat rate taxes on 12 of 12
no payroll taxes no medicare no medicaid
no
excise taxes no corporate taxes no
personal income taxes
no capital gains taxes no death taxes
all federal taxes gone except for sin
taxes which are a teeny tiny portion all
of that could be replaced by this
without even assuming a laffer curve i
mean that's what jerry brown ran down we
went from eighth in the race in the
democratic primary in 92
to second in the race and i think we
would have won the race
if if jerry hadn't picked his vice
president the way he did
uh if we did that i mean you would have
that low rate can you imagine
you pay you're paid 100 bucks patrick
and
what you have to do is send an 87 send
in 13
uh bucks and you get to keep 87. or
better yet your employer gives you 87
and they send in 13 before you you don't
even have to file a tax return for
goodness sakes
i mean that's what we should have as
taxes so we have
a complete if you want to help people
who don't have income who are
in some sense dire circumstances okay
write him a check you know what does a
what does an income
tax credit do to a mother with kids who
doesn't file a tax return
nothing you know what you want to do is
write them a check
so they get the check clear and you're
not confusing the tax system with a
spending system what was the biggest
pushback jerry got when
when you guys pitched that tax plan well
the only pushback we got was we kept
getting better and better and better in
the votes
i mean we came in with the second most
numbered delegates in the democratic
primary with the flat tax
huh how's that for cool and he would
have won
three weeks out of the new york park we
just won the kinetic primary
and we just won the oregon primary we're
coming into new york and california
and he announces jesse jackson as his
running mate
it stopped but you know look at that's
jerry brown i mean i love the guy
dearly but he loves to stir the pot
but we still got the second most number
of delegates in the democratic primary
with a complete flat tax not with a uba
not with a negative income tax without
just a flat rate tax
and then when you want to help someone
write them a damn check are you familiar
with jordan peterson
no jordan peterson is uh you know wrote
a book 12 rules for life
a very renowned author he was a clinical
psychologist at
university of toronto he became well i
have heard of him yes i have i've
watched him on tv yes once he's really
pretty amazing
fascinating genius brilliant guy people
people love
the way he thinks and what he says about
so one of the things he talks about he
says
about 10 of america has an iq below 83
which is a net negative to society right
about 10
of america's got a iq less than 83
net negative to society so we're talking
about you know
fiscal responsibility great you know hey
take care of your money go to work take
you make you you know save your money
put it on a rod put it in an ira put it
away you know match the 401k whatever
take care of your family some people are
saying
that there's a 10 percent that no matter
how we set up the economy
that 10 is not going away meaning if
there's that one percent at the top
that's gonna find a way to make their
millions and then there's a one percent
of the one percent that's going to be
billionaires
the same way is the bottom 10 that no
matter what you do with taxes
there's going to be 10 percent of people
that are going to need to help
to have the government or an
organization help them out
so what how do you process that where we
have to be fiscally responsible yes
but there is a small percentage of
community that
maybe doesn't have the capability as
others or what some of these experts are
uh
implying what are your thoughts on that
where we have to also be
socially responsible to take care of
those folks i do
agree with it a hundred percent i mean
you know i am completely in accord
with helping those who can't help
themselves and
not only help them but you know we as a
society just can't afford to allow
these people to live in pain and
suffering it's just not right
but now what you want to make sure
patrick and it's a balancing act here
is you want to make sure that you don't
make the benefits
the social welfare benefits so
attractive
that you cause people to become poor
because they get paid for being poor
now what i would do in this sort of
thing is uh i
i would surely have a soup kitchen's
housing for the people who really
you know the people living under bridges
and all that stuff just give them
physical things that they desperately
need
and want and have it there i'd love i
would have health clinics for the
poorest
uh but that's it i mean that's pretty
much what you do to them
uh if you have any institutions that
these people are are doing self-harm
there can be certain you know
all of those things to protect our
society i would really encourage
religious organizations and other groups
to make sure they step
in as well but you know uh you don't
want to kill
everything to help the one and that's
what you really got to make sure
you don't make the benefits so
attractive that you cause
able-bodied good productive people to
stop working and now
do you've seen that with the 300
unemployment benefits that extended
additional unemployment benefits these
people are not going back in the labor
force because it's more attractive
being unemployed than it is actually
going back to their old jobs
that is when welfare state has gone
crazy
but i have nothing whatsoever against
helping those who can't help themselves
and and doing it in the most generous
fashion possible
yeah it's it's just how we go about
doing that you know and it's
tough you know it's a tough call you say
iq i don't think i would use that by the
way i don't think i'd use the iq measure
at all because you know some people with
low iqs are damn great at calculating
and raising their own kids and all that
stuff
i mean i watched tom hanks and what was
it uh
saving private ryan or which one are you
talking about no no the uh the
the movie what was the movie forrest
gump yeah if he raising the kid there i
mean he did made it four
yeah four skunks having private ryan
yeah of course guys i would i wouldn't
uh i wouldn't
i wouldn't always just assign a
characteristic because
you see these people can really do well
but what you want to do is watch and
maintain and make sure
that that that doesn't go to where the
people are living in
harm i mean pain and suffering that's
just not what we're about
you know years ago late 70s you were
working on some policies i think was
prop 13
in california when it was the uh uh was
it a property tax or something like that
were you property tax limit yes
what approach so what was it and what
approach did you take to drastically
change the property taxes in california
well i first placed didn't do the
proposition that was done by paul
gann and howard jarvis it was called the
jarvis scan initiative there was their
fourth or fifth attempt and when i read
about it i did my analysis of supply set
economics
the property taxes at that time were 2.7
of market value patrick and uh what the
prop 13 would do was drop it to one
percent
so there'd be a huge cut in property tax
rates and i thought this would be
extremely attractive to bring businesses
back into california jobs
you know the poor and the minorities in
california don't move to
let's say tennessee to get jobs if the
jobs don't come into california they
don't get the job so
i argued that the jobs would flow into
california prices of housing would rise
that incomes would rise that the welfare
payments would fall so dramatically
because people would have jobs locally
that it would actually in due course pay
for itself which took it a year and a
half to completely pay for itself
i also talked with the then governor uh
the one i was just talking about a
minute ago jerry brown
i went up and he called me and asked me
to come up to sacramento
i came up and spent three days with him
in sacramento on how to
implement prop 13 to make it work jerry
brown was just spectacular he and his
cabinet
were just spectacular and what they did
was they did subventions now property
taxes
only impacted only impacted cities
counties and local districts
the state did not have a property tax
had an income tax and all these others
but not that so what he did was he
subvened
five billion dollars of state funds to
the city's counties and local districts
to make sure that they didn't have a
shortage of police fire
libraries schools all of that stuff he
made damn sure that happened
it did a great job and we pulled through
it and in the next decade we were the
fastest growing state in the nation
uh our property values more than doubled
relative to the rest of the nation
unemployment rate just tumbled in
california and we just prospered as
never be
we grew by a tire massachusetts
in that 10 years that next 10 years it
really worked and i'm
that's one of the things i'm really very
proud of even though i didn't author
that thing
it was just a great idea and i'm so glad
i came out and supported it
and i think it really made for a period
of prosperity in california
unparalleled on this planet well good
for you for giving credit to something
you're saying you were
you didn't write so so you talked you
just mentioned california when i was
with you in tennessee i think at that
time
they were saying the lowest all-in taxes
in all of america out of all the 50
states is tennessee tennessee was number
one when i was visiting it was
lowest to number lowest lowest yeah yeah
meaning the best
the best to be in the best climate to be
in right and at the time california was
the highest i think new york is now the
highest i think new york just passed
california with the 4.3 billion dollar
bill that just passed
wonderful victory well here's a here's a
question for you so
kovit i'm i lived in la 24 years minus
the time i was in the military you know
fort campbell kentucky hunter first but
i was in california 24 years
i was in dallas for five years and i've
been in florida now for five months i'm
moving in florida i have one of my
companies i kept in dallas
and i got another company i'm running
right now that's in florida during the
pandemic
we saw a lot of moving parts we saw how
california policies were pushing people
out of california a bunch of names i
don't need to give them to you you've
read them you know them
and the list will be a long list whether
a lot of the folks from california if
they could they move their business to
nevada no
state ain't no state taxes or they moved
straight up to
texas because it's a better business
friendly place and you saw a lot of
people from new york
d.c all in connecticut moving to florida
and now a lot of guys are saying i'm not
moving back to new york i kind of like
staying in
florida here from your experience you
said fifty years you've been studying
economy
has florida always been florida has
texas always been texas where it's a
pro-business-friendly place or did
california used to be texas
and new york used to be florida and they
flipped
i don't know if you understand the
question i'm asking i know i got the
question
let me just say that relative tax rates
have
always attracted to people to the lower
states
lower tax states from the higher tax
that's always been true and let me
if you have two locations a and b sure
if you raise taxes in b and you lower
them an a
people and jobs and producers and income
will move from
b to a that that will happen california
had a huge advantage
in the 60s i mean i moved there in the
60s because of the huge advantages that
california had
on all sorts of job prospects growth it
was where the earth began
uh but as the years have gone on uh tax
rates have become
much much more important as to how they
do it now
there have been 11 states that
introduced the income tax since 1960
those 11 states started in 1961 with
west virginia
it ended up in with a connecticut in
you know it had states like rhode island
and maine and new jersey and
pennsylvania and indiana and ohio and
illinois and michigan and nebraska
all of them put in the income all of
those states that introduced an income
tax
have declined dramatically relative to
the rest of the nation
i mean dramatically uh it's still nine
states in the u.s have no income tax no
earned income tax
we just got rid of our earned income tax
and the and the states with no income
tax
way outperformed those that have the
highest income taxes
i guess the question i was asking you is
so originally when new york and
california become new york and
california what attracted everybody to
move to new york in california was it
low income taxes
was it a big it was not low income taxes
i mean it it
it the taxes did not sorry low state
taxes
no i understand i understood exactly
what you meant no new york was a place
of opportunity there was growing to
building up
but once it had built up and all of that
advantage had occurred
uh in florida in 195 1947 was
nothing i mean it was arkansas i mean
excuse me i don't mean to insult
arkansas
but it was really a disaster california
in 1939 was nothing
i mean it was this it was world war ii
that really got california up and going
i mean all the troops going over there
and to fight in the far east and it
really built california up to huge size
so all of these states had a lot of
natural advantages
let me just say this really clearly
patrick that
taxes are not everything they're far far
far from it lots of other things matter
besides taxes
but taxes are important and taxes are
one of the items that
people look to when they move now if you
look at just taxes
you will not get every person's move
some people move because they're
girlfriends in a different state some
people move
because their company moved i mean all
these things happen but tax is the
common systematic boom
boom boom and if you look at tax rates
amongst the states
you will map out the fast growing states
and the slow growing
you'll see that michigan is declining
like mad to detroit in 1980
uh 1950 had 1.85 million people today
it's below 600 thousand
uh miami in 1950 had no one
now it's bazillions i mean you know all
of these things are moving
i mean just st louis and kansas city and
cleveland ohio and detroit
and chicago and all these cities that
are just collapsing before our eyes
in the high tax state look compared them
with dallas and houston
and san antonio and these other you know
it is a huge monumental earth
movement earthquake that's taken driven
in
large part by taxes and free market
regulations
and pro-growth policies uh that are
really making a big difference
last question here can what happened to
detroit michigan
you know where they went like you said
1.85 million to less than 600 000 and
you know
regulation after regulation after
regulation where more government jobs
are being offered them free enterprise
finally the other guys are like listen
we're out of here
it's a mess to be working here can what
happened to detroit
happen to new york or you know illinois
chicago or l.a california
yes it can now detroit it was easier to
do
i mean in 1950 detroit was the paris of
north america
i mean the train station there my mom
and dad used to take me by train up to
detroit
the train station there in detroit was
the taj mahal i mean it was just an
amazing building uh it can but it takes
a long time to destroy the capital stock
uh and it takes a long time to rebuild
it and the problem is that
once you've done those taxes uh the
first five years you get rid of those
taxes you'll get no revenues because no
one's coming back until they feel really
certain
about the long run and that's the
problem is it's like a ratchet you can't
undo it once you've done it again two
guys two guys
one's a two pack a day smoker the other
guy's never smoked a cigarette
both of those guys have to go the next
three months without any cigarettes okay
the guys never smoke says okay fine
what's what's the big deal
the smoker goes ah goes through delete
that's what happens when you try to
remove taxes the income tax
it's almost impossible because you'll
have huge shortfalls of revenue
for the next three or four or five years
your schools will have problems and all
of that will
now if you never adopt an income tax
you'll do
really well forever and the problem is
is undoing the damage that these guys
put in
one state has redu removed its income
tax
and that was alaska i was up there with
them when they discovered oil
they had this huge revenue surge and
they were able to use those revenues to
get
income tax on the sales tax but other
than that i've never seen any state get
rid of it but that's a different story i
mean
alaska is not it's not a duplicatable
story it's not correct yeah
yeah you're right totally right final
thoughts i'll give you here arthur you
know
my uh and the topic i would want to hear
from you on the final thoughts is
are you still as optimistic uh as the
idea of america for the average guy
to work their tails off have their
dreams become a reality
the fact that this is still 5 10 15 20
30 years from now it's going to be the
greatest country in the world or we've
reached a point where
you know look we're a couple bad
decisions away from ruining
a great idea that we put together in
1776 where are you at with that
i'm 81 years old back you know 30 years
from now it's a little bit long for me
but
i'll still play with that one let me
just say that
uh you know a lot of these things are
pessimistic for me i
sometimes wake up on the grumpy side of
the life and i'm not
not optimistic but when i stop and think
about it for a second
in 1945
the highest marginal income tax rate in
the u.s was 94
today it's 37 that's not bad when jack
kennedy took office the corporate rate
the highest corporate rate was 52
now it's uh 15 that's not too shabby
you know if you look at the state income
tax state
death taxes in 1976 one state
alone did not have a death tax that was
nevada
today i think 38 states have gotten rid
of their death taxes
in 1957 uh i think of 1957 two states
had right to work
that was arkansas and florida today half
the states have right to work which is
wonderful
we've got the we've got the deregulation
in the stock market
in 1973 it cost you 30 cents to trade a
share of stock
today it's zero uh and jimmy carter
deregulated airlines
totally now you've got much lower costs
of air travel a lot more people
traveling
and it's safer they de-controlled they
de-controlled trucking as well
they not only controlled trucking as
well but they've done a lot on
negotiating discount for it used to be
against the law to sell products at a
discount
now we've got walmart and costco and all
these other places do discounts
it's an amazingly better world i mean if
you look at the
some of the wildlife i mean the bald
eagles back the black-footed ferrets
back
cuyahoga cleveland ohio is
pollution-free well not quite
pollution-free but
the hudson river i mean if you look at
the
la basin when i lived there you couldn't
see mount baldy
99 of the time now you can see it
everywhere you used to have three stage
smog alerts all the time
you know we're making huge progress in a
positive direction
and government is part of the solution
it's not
just a problem it's thinking about
government correctly that will allow us
to use government
as a tool to create prosperity you know
you want to collect your taxes in the
least damaging fashion
and you want to spend your money in the
most beneficial fashion
when the damage done by the last dollar
of taxes collected
is a bit less than the benefit run by
the last dollar spent
stop already any spending higher than
that is too much
but any spending lower than that is too
little there is a correct role for
government
these guys think that if good
government's good god you should
increase it tenfold
no i mean a little bit of salt on your
eggs in the morning is great but a whole
pile of salt on it really tastes awful
and they need limitations on this and
that's what i'm hoping we discover
as we move forward i'm i'm really
hopeful of that will be the case
i hope jerry the jerry brown story
inspires the biden
administration to contact even for some
council on what could work and what
can't work because if those ideas almost
worked
back in the days minus the vp who would
have chosen i think some of those ideas
many people would like to see
presented to the president the name is
dr lamfer
if you haven't read his book return to
prosperity we're going to put the link
below
dr arthur laffer thank you once again
for being a guest on valuetainment
my pleasure thank you very much patrick
very different angles right taxes
economy future how he feels about
bitcoin cryptocurrency gold
inflation not really in inflation i
thought it was fascinating
want to know what you took away from it
comment below and if you enjoyed this
interview
my part one with uh arthur laffer was
right here in 2018
we went a complete different angle if
you've not seen that click over here
or another video i did a month ago
titled the history of taxes where i went
very deep
in the history of taxes you may want to
watch that as well take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]